Наприкінці липня заступниця голови Верховної Ради Оксана Сироїд
в інтерв'ю радіо "Новое Время" заявила,
Президент України, відповідно до стандартів НАТО, не може командувати армією,
контролювати армію і контролювати армійський бюджет,
тому що це суперечить стандартам НАТО.
DW перевірила,
Ми проаналізували, яку роль в керуванні армією відіграють очільники країн-членів НАТО.
Головнокомандувачем найбоєздатнішими у світі збройними силами США,
згідно з конституцією, є президент країни.
Головнокомандувач має право на оголошення надзвичайного стану,
проведення часткової мобілізації, накази про участь військ США у бойових діях,
а також, у критичному випадку, колегіально з міністром оборони ухвалювати рішення
на застосування ядерної зброї.
Конгрес США є основним органом цивільного контролю над діяльністю Збройних сил.
Главою збройних сил Німеччини - Бундесверу - є федеральний міністр оборони,
який є головнокомандувачем у мирний час.
За конституцією країни, у разі настання необхідності оборонних дій
командування переходить канцлеру Німеччини, який є фактичним главою держави.
У Франції головнокомандувачем і у мирний, і у військовий час є президент країни.
Саме глава держави призначає начальника Генерального штабу французької армії.
Президент також ухвалює рішення
про початок закордонних військових операцій французькою армією.
Глава Франції  має код доступу до систем запуску ядерних ракет.
Відповідно до основного закону Італійської Республіки,
президент є главою держави і  головнокомандувачем збройними силами,
а також головує у Вищій Раді Оборони.
В Україні її аналог - Рада Національної Безпеки і Оборони.
Вища Рада Оборони під головуванням президента Італії
розглядає проблеми національної оборони і визначає подальшу політику.
У Великобританії, Іспанії, Данії, Норвегії традиційно, за основним законом,
прописане право монархів як головнокомандувачів,
однак фактично рішення у галузі оборони ухвалюють колегіально
з прем'єр-міністрами і міністрами оборони.
У Королівстві Нідерландів - головнокомандувач прем'єр-міністр.
Твердження заступниці голови Верховної Ради Оксани Сироїд про те,
що, відповідно до стандартів НАТО, президент не може командувати армією, є помилковим.
Майже у всіх країнах Альянсу головнокомандувачами є глави держав.
У ядерних країнах-членах НАТО президенти мають право на застосування атомної зброї.
Також очільники деяких країн Альянсу призначають начальників Генштабів.
Звісно, умовою вступу до НАТО є демократичний контроль над збройними силами,
якого неухильно дотримуються і після набуття членства.